Now, let's go ahead and
declare some variables for
each of the primitive
types that we saw earlier.
So, now we have a couple more variables,
and I've explicitly stated the type for
each, even though it's
really not necessary.
Except for the case of the float and
the double.
The character would be the same as well.
So, I'll leave that one.
I'm going to remove all
the other ones really quick.
But the rest of them,
I think Swift will infer just fine, and
we can double check.
So that's in that like we wanted.
That's a string.
And that's a bool.
Now, what about these float and
double types?
They seem to represent pretty similar
values, they're floating point numbers.
But why would you use
one over the other?
Well that comes down to
an issue of precision and
being able to most accurately
represent a floating point number.
Truth be told, computers actually have
a pretty difficult time doing this.
Usually computers even have
special hardware dedicated just to
floating point numbers.
Typically you'll want to use
double instead of float,
because it can handle floating point
numbers at a higher precision.
But, double isn't always better.
In cases where speed may be more
important than the accuracy of
a floating point number,
you may want to choose float instead.
Next let's try changing
a variable's value.
Let's change myJerseyNumber.
Since we've already
declared myJerseyNumber,
we can just change it with
the simple syntax here.
We have the name of the variable,
an equal sign and
then the new value that we want.
So following this change we can see that
my jersey number went from being 5 here
to 80 here.
And we can keep doing this
as many times as we'd like.
However, when we change
a variables value,
we must insure that the new
value is of the right type.
So in this case,
every single one of these are integers,
so the compiler wouldn't complain.
But let's try something
a little bit different.
In this case, we're going to
try to change myJerseyNumber
to something would typically
be inferred as a string.
And this is a problem.
We can see that the compiler's
complaining, and
it says we cannot assign a value of
type string to a value of type n
because myJerseyNumber was declared
as an integer, it specs an integer.
And the reason this is a problem is
because Swift is strongly typed.
Or we might say that Swift is
a strongly typed language.
This means that once a variable's
type has been declared or
set, it cannot change.
So if we look at where myJerseyNumber is
declared, we know that it's an integer.
And it can't change.
Therefore, it can't be
set to the string here.